you
welcome to seee TV on cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday my name
is Jay Smith and today I will be talking
to Gwen Shapiro from confluent how are
you doing today fantastic being with you
I want to make sure you all know that
you can ask questions on our platform
and we have Google errs on buy or sell
and stand by to answer them and we might
answer some of them later on now let's
get started actually I had the pleasure
of meeting Gwen few times and she was at
strata in New York City and got to see
some interesting stuff she's the kind of
the Guru hear about Kafka that was a fun
event I hope you also enjoyed it I did
so let's let's get a little bit of your
background yeah so I work for confluence
it's a company that was started by the
people who first created Apache carska
and we do all CAF call the time from
support to building a lot of tools that
make it easier to run to running it
ourselves on confluent cloud among
others on Google cloud so yeah so
basically I want to be here today to
kind of talk to you about Kafka and how
people use it and what's going on there
awesome let's get right to it then yeah
so I was way off starting with just kind
of a simple stream processing example
kind of to explain what we're talking
about when we say that Apache Kafka is
really a streaming platform and then
kind of do a quick intro to just the
concepts of Kafka and the components
around it so two maybe even three cool
use cases and then jump into them and
show you how it implements those cases I
got a really cool demo for you actually
I like cold demo so do our viewers so
basically we say that Kafka is streaming
platform what is it actually mean it
means that you can produce events Kafka
will store them as ordered stream events
it will maintain this order and then you
can consume those events and you can
even consume them do stuff to them and
write them back to Kafka which is what
we call
stream processing so just to show you
what stream processing could look like
imagine
someone trying to being a credit card
processor so you get a lot of Tours
Asian attempts from credit cards
everyday at thousands and thousands
every second a tiny percentage of them
could be incredibly suspicious so we
need to detect those suspicious events
and separate them from the good events
and basically have someone investigate
them in between right and it sounds like
it could be very complicated to be
honest doing it in real life is pretty
complicated but it can start with
something incredibly simple if someone
is trying to repeatedly authorize the
same card over and over again it's
probably very suspicious so we want to
basically filter this stream of
histories Asian attempts for this kind
of behavior and create a new stream of
things that may possibly be wrong and we
want to do it every time an event
happens we want to do it continuously
that's the core of stream processing not
just once a day because way then the bad
guys may be already all the way back to
somewhere and who knows we may never
catch them again so we want to
continuously process it and as you can
see using SQL is like simplest way to do
stream processing even if you know
almost nothing about streams or Java
right this looks very similar to your
standard sequel maybe a few little
differences exactly so just to show you
how it works we basically say okay we're
doing and creating a new stream of
possible fronts based on an existing
stream of authorization attempts and the
way we select possible fraud is that we
look at five minutes window so we cut
down the stream into five minute windows
and pick the card number and count the
authorization attempts of the code this
card in this window and then say
everything with more than three in a
5-minute window it looks like a
suspicious card and we're writing into
possible fraud and then we have a straw
ongoing stream of single that looks
suspicious now we want to basically send
it somewhere else for deeper analysis
where may be qualified women can do
extra investigation so really the core
idea of streaming is that you don't
process events once in a while new
processing is there going on
in real time that's really if you learn
nothing else about three important
things that is the concept you have to
remember so how do we do it so let's
look at really the components that make
up this platform and the core component
is the cash flow brokers or what we also
call along or distributed load there is
a famous book by my co j krebs called I
love logs where he basically explains
that log is the fundamental data
structure of all modern computing and it
turns out that logs are incredibly
simple it is a data structure where you
write things at the end and you store
this structure in order for a set amount
of time which could be forever some
people do like hundreds of years amount
of time and you can see that this could
be your application log this can be a
clique stream this can be a credit card
authorization attempt the it's a message
is so generic like an event is anything
that has happened would be it and so you
keep writing events at the end and then
different applications who want to read
it and that is it every application is
independent and they start at some point
usually the beginning and they continue
in one direction hopefully to the end
and there is one direction of movement
which makes it just efficient on disks
and it's faster and also each one of
those consumers only needs to know ok
the last message I got is message 5 the
next one is going to be message 6 let me
ping the broker and say can I get a
message 6
can I get message 7 it's actually a bit
you get to [ __ ] more than just the next
message but that's the idea which means
that the clients and the broker don't
need to keep track every single event
and did everyone consume it and who's
supposed to consume it this is one of
the things that were always a bit a more
computationally intensive and memory
intensive in old message buses and
really set apart so since it's all in
order it's easier to keep track of yes
exactly you just have to remember one
number of in course women so sometimes
people ask me how many consumers can I
have with kapha and I know 2,000 50,000
it's just one number how much there's a
long take right exactly
and then I just showed you one look
which in kafka terms is one partition a
Kafka topic is made up of a lot of
partitions and then the topic is kind of
this logical entity maybe like a
database table and then Khafre is made
up of a lot of those topics and I'm
going to show you a lot of topics when I
we do the demo and well that's the idea
is that the topic will have many
partitions you can spread them across
many machines you have many producers
writing to them many consumers reading
so it's really a scalable system the
other thing is that each partitions also
replicated usually on three machines so
you have a leader all reads and writes
go to the leader and then the followers
basically keep replicating things you
have one job keep replicating and if
something happens leader basically one
of the replicas take over the idea is
that because all reads and writes
happened later we always have full
consistency on that partition which is
really a core quarantine that after his
that's good yeah good I mean if you have
all those events in one of the machines
goes down heaven forbid you want to make
sure you can maintain those events so
having this replica technology exactly
and usually when things go wrong is
because people miss configure
replication and think they have
guarantees they actually don't so you
can see here it's kind of really
scalable end to end from producers
through partitions to consumers and
consumers they really have the idea of
consumer group so if one consumer
instance cannot handle all the data from
all the partitions because you know
thousands of credit card per second is a
lot of work you can actually start
multiple instances and belong to the
same consumer group and they will
basically negotiate with each other and
say okay this one is reading this
partition the other ones reading the
other partition and you get scalability
on the consumer applications and also
high availability from of those crushes
basically the partitions will get
reassigned to someone else so it's
really scalable and resilient end-to-end
and then if you go to the Apache Kafka
project you will only really get clients
in two languages the Java and Scala but
Kafka has a binary protocol that is only
slightly complex and so a lot of people
started implementing this binary
protocol in different languages so you
have a pretty big ecosystem in all those
different languages and then if your
language is not supported you have a
rest proxy that will give you support
pretty much everyone does rest right
exactly and that's great because a lot
of times when you want to learn a new
tool there's a limitation and based on
whatever it's software or whatever
language it supports but being able to
support a wide array of languages I can
just take whatever knowledge I have
today take advantage of the the surest
proxy do you know expect them to learn
new languages faster than we did in the
past
oh yeah there's like three new ones
every month or no I spent most of my
career with Java and then suddenly it's
like oh I have to learn go and now I was
told to trust is a really big deal and
cotton is a really big like everything
keeps happening so and it's funny I have
a friend who's now learning rust and
he's like you think I can just write a
Kafka producer is my first project and
I'm like go for it yeah maybe he'll
write one in Julia too now oh maybe if
you have spare time I don't know do you
do hack projects that kind of thing
sure why not yeah 20% time right that's
the so until now I kind of explained how
you produce and consume events from your
applications that you coded yourself but
there is a lot of cases where the data
you want is not something that you
actually create yourself it's actually
already exists in some database and you
can't really ask the person writing to
do the best to please also write to
crash cry because they have their own
priorities well you can really connect
to the database and get events to Kafka
with the connect framework I mean you
could write it yourself in your own app
but there is so much in common between
all those different paul and produce
loops that we figure that we may well
give you the framework and let you focus
on how to query the other database so
it's a very basic idea that get data
from a database
into Kafka or from Kafka into database
you don't have to do the entire flow
just what half of it is fine but you
know them I'll show you the entire flow
and obviously once you write a good API
communities are kind of amazing so
hundreds of connectors showed up from
all those different teams and companies
like the Google the big connector from
Kafka to Google bigquery was written by
a company called we pay and they just
open sourced it and now like ten other
companies also use it because apparently
getting data from Kafka to bigquery is a
very big day yeah Kafka we must have
emphasized the fact that it is open
source it is very community driven compo
and it's very active in that community
so you do get a lot of these third party
connectors and tools built for it
due to its open source nature exactly
exactly and for me it's just always
amazing the creativity of the community
did you ever want to get events from a
Bloomberg terminal into an IRC channel
for example and then the last component
is really doing the stream processing
and I kind of already showed you how it
works in the beginning so I don't have
to go over that again but I wanted to
mention that this is kind of friendly
SQL but it's a layer on top of a java
api and a skull api is that you can
really use more directly if you prefer
using Java and Scala which a lot of us
really do and it does give you a bit
more power and flexibility at the
expense of slightly more complexity
which seems like the usual trade-off in
pretty much everything all right yeah
being able to essentially query the
stream so as it's writing to the logs
you're able to get information not
actually just waiting until it actually
and I'll show you that on screen real
time like just type a query and see the
events coming it's pretty awesome
and yeah and this is like six lines of
code or so and it's six lines because we
broke it up I wrote the same thing in
Java you know it already huge amounts of
code but it was definitely three screen
full of lines written so having the
ability to really do it quickly is
pretty big for
busy developers so what can we do is is
like our listeners at home may want to
go and write their own stream processing
framework what's it what could they do
so one thing that we see very often is
how companies have those clicks of
events that are actually meaningful
information that they want to analyze
sometimes from web applications or
mobile apps and then they may want to
enrich the event with things that they
know about the user so some that
profiles that come from database query
maybe even log files to see if there's
correlation with different errors that
happened and you can really bring all of
those into Kafka probably into different
topics use case you want to join window
aggregate do whatever you want and then
you can really stream the events into
external systems like Google bigquery so
you can do more analytical work and
that's one thing to emphasize case QL is
fantastic for kind of data managing
joining grouping and it works really
nicely real time but it's not like
please query the last five years of data
a kind of thing and there is a lot of
stuff that really you want to write a
graph to an external system so you can
do a lot more involved analytical work
right so you wouldn't necessarily try to
train a model with K sequel just getting
the information that you need you really
need clean how equality data this is
where we see the connectors in case you
will really come in but a big question
is how do we actually do it how do we
get data from Kafka to bigquery and it's
one of the things that I had my own
opinion and I thought it's obvious and
then I asked other people and they had
their opinion and they said it's obvious
yes I want to go through some options so
the old-school way is to something
called seeker which is about basically
batch job highly paralyzed back job so
sinkovitz is a big MapReduce job and it
basically goes connects to Kafka starts
consuming events and write them to
bigquery in part but this is a batch job
so it will run once an hour or so and
while it's pretty cool and it's flexible
and does all kind of cool things and we
did a lot of work to make sure we get
the data in real time
we don't want to lose the real-time
aspect just before we land in bigquery
so we also picked up a bunch of
streaming options and you can use the
stream processing frameworks and I gave
us examples Kafka streams and Apache
beam and obviously yeah Google dataflow
and this is big full-fledged programming
languages it gives you a lot of control
over what your data is going to look
like so if you need to do a lot of
standardization a lot of clean up get
some date over here some that over there
bunch of filtering you can really write
those jobs and do basically get events
clean them up write them to bigquery and
of course it's programming so you have
to actually write all of it yourself
all the error handling all the schema
handling all those is your own code a
casual Connect is pretty much the polar
opposite it is still streaming but it's
basically a no code option you give it
I'll show you basically write a big
configuration file and you say ok I'm
getting data from this topic to this
bigquery data set into that table and
you expect Kafka connect to handle
everything for you more or less so you
sound like if this does your job you are
done in five minutes while writing code
can take a big testing cycle and if you
actually need to control then I mean it
would be nice if I could do it in five
minutes but I can't so all right so it's
great for getting started you know it's
amazing for getting started I'll show
you how quickly you can get you down
it's I'm singing that these days
engineering is under a lot of stress to
deliver things in very short time cycle
and a lot of times like you have to show
results before to get allocated the time
to do anything smarter so like hey look
at how I'm getting events from Kafka to
bigquery fantastic oh but I really need
the events in slightly different format
so let's the next sprint the next two
weeks I'm going to really try to do
something a bit more involved and then
once we know how to collect a lot of
events into Kafka and write them into
bigquery
why stop
with clicks right I mean there is a lot
of useful data in those legacy data
systems and in your application and you
can use it for example maybe running a
bank and you have your credit card
processing you have transaction and you
have loan requests and you have a lot of
old information about the customers and
legacy systems bring them all together
and processing them getting them to
Google bigquery with things like connect
or Google data flow depending on the use
case and then you really have a lot of
data here to process imagine trying to
get access to the data on the legacy
mainframe and the tools you would have
to use to do it and like just how long
the process will take versus doing
experimentation in data that shows up in
real time it's a very big difference in
quality of life and then if you want to
get like if you got the simple use case
is working you can do such things that
are more advanced and obviously more
exciting I think it's works I think a
lot of data these days comes from
devices yes it does IOT is being my life
easier maybe a tad lazier everything all
of my outlets are wired and I just speak
into my Google home and turn on
everything turn off everything actually
yeah that's pretty cool yeah I'm not
that advanced but I do have things like
nest and those programmable lightbulbs
if I want to do set up a mood in my
house and it's a lot of fun so basically
all of those devices a very small number
of protocols a common one is mqtt and a
part of the confluent platform is an mqt
proxy so you can really collect
information from those devices stream it
into the cloud when the nice thing about
clouds is probably a cloud center near a
region nearby - from where the device is
and then you can really start doing
advanced things like you can train a
model and using the same data you can
also serve the model in real time
something like google functions serving
up the model on every event as it
happens so you can really start with
something fairly pedestrian like like
stream processing and end up with in
real time machine learning
IOT system that is probably something
that you can raise some money with so
obviously results that you want to
actually use all those cool tools you
don't necessarily want to install them
configure them figure out why they're
losing data or maybe they're not losing
them and why they're not losing the
other wise are not losing that about
doing it too far too slow or too fast
managing it upgrading it troubleshooting
it getting the pager is 3:00 a.m. oh no
not for a while but I do remember
getting those alerts me yeah I'm just
thinking like my last pager job was
maybe in 2009 so basically it's reducing
there nothing to think it's been around
for a while but the idea is that you
could run it yourself Kafka is open
source you can install and run it or you
can let us run it for you on Google
platform and it's kind of I'll show you
it's kind of integrated with yeah one
thing I always tell users developers you
know when you're building your
application if it's not something that
is core to your your project if it's
something that you need but it managing
it doesn't really add value it's always
best to have somebody else manage it
that way you can focus all your time
resources energies on to the things that
actually matter for your application or
your business and a really funny thing
is that I've been working with the same
companies for a bunch of years now and
it's funny how like a company that 3
years ago or like we are never going to
use cloud clouds will not work for our
banking system and then three years
later like oh we are you know we're
actually starting to move to the cloud
we could use some help
how what's a good architecture for
migrating to the cloud what's a good use
case how do we do cloud security
executing just the economics of it are
kind of invisible why would you want to
run your own data center it's not your
competency absolutely it it just doesn't
make sense to do if it doesn't if it
doesn't benefit your application at the
end of the day exactly
focus on things you're actually good at
in banking case taking our money look at
confluent cloud
let me try to switch to in demo okay so
I'm already logged into the confluent
cloud and you can see that I basically
have a bunch of clusters already here if
I want to add a new one it's really not
a big deal so let's say I'm going to
test something you know and you can see
I can kind of play around with how much
that time consuming and producing
important bit is to select the right
provider right region
how many availability zones and I
knew--i click continue look this is
going to cost us a half $1 per hour and
we're here for an hour so you I think
you better pay up
alright I'll send it to you over google
pay okay so after I launched the cluster
and basically see a bunch of
instructions on how to installed a sick
load which is based on inspired by G
cloud which we all know in love and this
allows me to basically use the cloud
from the command line so basically I can
do something like see cloud topics list
and because I'm already connected to one
of my classes you can see I have a
pretty big list of topics going on here
I wish they sorted them it's kind of not
really sorted I can create a new topic a
new topic and I can produce events into
a topic if I want to so let me show you
how I produce events do that
so this was the new topic I created
you
okay so I produced an event super simple
and now I want to obviously consume it
and I'm doing minus B so it could start
consuming from the beginning otherwise
you only get new events and you'll see
they're stirring for a long time why is
nothing showing up so this does take a
bit of time because we need to negotiate
the consumer group and see if someone
else's connects but here's a low so hey
if you're following at home this may be
the first event you produce and consume
I'd know for me when I teach classes
it's always exciting to see people
produce and consume their first event
but what I really wanted to show you is
how I build a pipeline so how do I get
events from Wikipedia and maybe running
SQL prayer query and then write them too
big way means we you can show me how to
do a query on bigquery okay so I'm
switching to a confluent control center
and and basically you can see all the
topics here but I really wanted to show
you the connectors so you can see that I
have a Wikipedia connector and I only
expand that connector as they don't
require to write code you basically
configure them so over here I basically
configure the Wikipedia server
it's an IRC server koopida publishes all
everything that happens to a bunch of
channels and you can see all the chance
that I'm reading from it's basically a
channel for every language and I'm
writing all of them to the same
Wikipedia topic so let me start that and
then let's go and see look at the data
so I'm looking for the Wikipedia topic
when I click here you can see I have a
bunch of screen so I can see the schema
in the topic and I can take a look you
can see this is real time event you can
see more events are coming in and I can
see the new event and so if you actually
see the data so we're common Wikipedia
and this user edited this page you put
in this message I find it pretty cool
yeah now if I want to actually run a
query I can go oh it's an able to
connect I cannot run queries for you I'm
sorry it's alright yes
see what else we gonna do here yeah
that's how what happens on these things
that you do in tests the night before
all right mm-hmm
that's how they must work but I can go
to the sink and basically say so
Wikipedia edits will not exist because
that's the one with the things that who
were supposed to get processed but
Wikipedia we can still get Wikipedia
events into bigquery so we add it here
and here you can see that I'm getting
events from those two topics and I'm
basically a mapping them so we could PD
Eddie's go to Wikipedia edit so
Wikipedia goes to Wikipedia so that's
basically a topic two table mapping for
a big hurry and you can say this is my
bigquery project and this is the name of
the data set of leukopenia
it took me a long time to figure out how
the oldest terminology works but it is
the same terminology if you know
bigquery it will probably be a lot
easier for you than it was for me I
figured out how to use the JSON key file
to actually authorize my bigquery user
and so now after I figure it all out I
can start my connector and I think let's
go to the I don't know how to switch
tabs so it's going to be this all right
yes so this is my Google dashboard and
here I have bigquery you can see they
have a data set and the day I have to
create the data set but so before I saw
the collector I had to create the
Wikipedia data set but the table will
basically be automatically created based
on the mapping and the schema will be
automatically created based on the
schema of the events in kavkaza they
kind of showed you and if I make a
change to the event in Kafka if I could
use kiss give all to actually edit the
event it will the change will
automatically reflect in bigquery so
that's pretty cool
oh it actually shows me all my query
history I didn't know it does that
that's neat so I can actually see well
we'll do something like well you can see
all of those were new key PD edits but I
want to do something from does it do
autocomplete
and yeah source can talk to you product
manager autocomplete will put it on and
let's get just like few of those what
them anything if I click here it will
just run the query for me worry table
yeah
oh I needed to have like the fully
qualified a oh it's alright belay we
don't have results from today yet no
it's still new
that's alright though yeah we've all
been yeah exactly so you can see here
basically do Wikipedia pages you can see
the channels I can also show you since I
think I still have all data from the
Wikipedia edits I can probably show you
how I enriched it's wisk SQL backbone
cast us can work for me I want to get
really yeah partition yeah probably not
give an asterisk to yeah I really like
how it shows the errors that they have
that's super helpful yeah
and now it's gonna work say it parses
everything in the real time
that's real time just it's a lot more
usability to pretty much everything so
you can see here that I added the
readable date so now you know that I did
all my practice five days ago and if you
go to the end you can see that I added
the language and the way the language is
that it's based see the channel name is
like FR dot wikipedia i basically joined
it with a table that i created that has
mapping of the channel to the language
and then I could do a join and get
awesome that is pretty awesome so
basically this allows us to get events
from Wikipedia to a Kafka if we were
lucky even do some
extreme processing and then right use
connect to write to the events to
bigquery and all that in real time so
this is just one of the many ways we can
use Kafka and comp form cloud exactly
yes the next next time we'll try to demo
terms of IOT device that kind of drives
around here exactly
great yes so just in case people want to
try it huh here we are and basically we
have confluent called professional which
is exactly DUI that I showed you so you
can just you write control and dot cloud
or you click on that you go to that URL
and you basically sign up and you say
it's like half a dollar per hour so and
building this pipeline takes just I know
an hour and right you can it's basically
something that you can get started with
fairly easily okay all right well that
was great I have stay tuned for a live
Q&A we will come back in about a minute
and we will answer your questions about
confident cloud and Kafka can't wait
you
welcome back it looks like we've got
some really good questions so why don't
we jump right into them how secure is
data and confluent cloud what measures
do you have in place to protect data
yeah so Kafka itself has basically the
authorization and authentication
encryption the things you need to keep
safe in confident cloud by default all
the communication is SSL encrypted so
you have encryption on the wire we use
encrypted storage to store the data so
you have encryption on disk and you
authorize with basically you get an API
key and the secret as long as you keep
them safe we don't even know them and
basically that's the authentication
method and if you are even more paranoid
than that and you don't a lot of people
I mean in this case I exposed my Kafka
to the world like I could just use it
from my laptop from the Google Wi-Fi
with no issues but if you want to limit
the access to just within your own data
center and just within your company VPN
then we also support the VPC peering so
you can use this two-way I have an even
more secure experience to be honest like
I'm exposing my toy clusters to the
Internet but I wouldn't probably do it
if it was actually running my bank right
and then being hosted on Google cloud
you guys you get to have the added
benefit of the security that Google
cloud offers yeah for example your load
balancer is probably what keeps us safe
from video s effects so exactly we
currently have some applications running
in our data center but we would also
like to use bigquery in real time with
data generated by our on-premises
applications is this possible with Kafka
I think I just showed that it is right I
mean you don't have to get data from
Wikipedia it was a cute demo but you can
really get the data from anything that
you produce to Kafka on the cloud you
can use connect and the bigquery
connector to get a data to a Google
bigquery if you don't want to use the
bigquery connector or you can also use
data flow or Kafka streams or something
[ __ ] or codes that you wrote yourself
because you are not invented here person
the sky is the limit right Paris API
you're able to write a lot yeah we have
implemented Kafka ourselves and have
been running it for three years now as a
Kafka adoption increased we are
experiencing some issues it is lagging
quite a bit and this is impacting our
business do you have any recommendations
on what we should look into oh oh that
is a pretty tuning is a big topic so I'm
going to assume that you're running on
come from the cloud and obviously the
brokers are running perfectly well so
it's really more about looking into your
a consumers like your application why is
it lagging so first of all kudos for
noticing that your application is
lagging we've seen people who do not
monitor consumer lag and therefore don't
even know that their application is
lagging so if you monitoring it and you
know it's lagging you're already a step
ahead of everyone else and then if we
look most the lag monitoring tools
definitely in control center but I think
also the rest of them they will
basically show you how what a lag looks
like is it increasing decreasing you
fell behind the new cannot catch up it
will also show you how many partitions
you have how many consumers you have and
the lag on each partition so you can say
oh actually this consumer is reading
from five partitions well the other two
consumers are barely reading from two
partitions and we need to somehow
reassign partitions and rebalance
because it's clear why this one is
falling behind you can say oh it's one
consumer a hundred partitions lots of
data gets written it may have been okay
ten years ago maybe not okay now and
then sometimes you also have a problem
where one partition just gets more data
and you need to consider your the keys
that you're writing how do you really
distribute the events through partitions
to avoid this kind of skew because it
can also cause you to lag if you're
running Kafka or yourself obviously
there is a lot of issues that can happen
it can be that a broker is handling a
lot more work than the rest and you need
to rebalance it can be that you have a
bad disk for that matter like it can be
a lot of different things
great well battery that helps narrow it
down a little bit that's the nice thing
about not surrounding the broker so if
at least you knows at this part you can
figure it out who is a call to support
and then you only have to worry about
the rest exactly
we're a cloud native company and are
looking for coffee as a service what are
some things we should consider when
selecting a particular service good
question we have a lot of people
nowadays that are born in the cloud
their applications never saw an
on-premise data center yeah so I mean
for me I'm a very much open source
person I think you should try to avoid
looking and try to make sure using open
source software open standards and just
a look at the community and make sure
that where you're working with the
communities that you enjoy working with
and you obviously want to make sure that
the people running in the software are
actually capable of supporting it and I
mean I guess it is but this is just due
diligence and then named testimonials is
always a good thing
whenever somebody I try to find who's
used it what they use how they felt
about it it's an important template to
emphasize though that confluent has a
lot of the original designers creators
of Kafka so yeah that's one way that
that's that's a little bit of a soldier
saying is it just a developer you want
to work with nice tools I think the
reasons that I enjoy Google cloud and
really was something to try to emulate
in confront cloud is really have a nice
command line okay API is at her useable
just make sure that it's a good you're
going to spend a lot of time in that
environment if you're a developer so it
has to be a nice environment okay final
question we are heavily invested in GCP
and our adopting Kafka is confluent
Kafka the same as GCP Kafka is that a
native GCP service well I can answer the
GCP part today we do not have a
scoff go but we have a partnership with
confluence supervise you managed Kafka
on GCP yeah so the big difference I
guess is that if it's not an active GCP
service you don't get to see it on the
big Google Dashboard works so bigquery
for example but other than that we are
running on the GCP infrastructure I
think specifically on Jukka you were
using all the available in Google
tooling and so yeah it is not a DCP
Kafka but hopefully you kind of get a
GCP experience that you know in love
right and running confluent cloud on GCP
is just you know you can integrate with
every other GCP tool like we saw
bigquery earlier maybe to cloud machine
learning and cloud functions a pinch and
pretty much anything you see on GCP yeah
I mean I haven't shown that but I'm
actually running a Kafka streams job
running on Google kübra gke so the
google kubernetes engine and that
connects to my confluent cloud and
another way to integrate your apps with
Google ecosystem excellent I think
that's all the questions we have for
today
so I'd like to thank you going for
coming out and thank you so much very
much sharing with the world everything
about Kafka and confluent cloud and how
it could take your events to the next
level when the events that your apps
generate in your devices those Smart
Switches cameras and everything and keep
everything real-time exactly so stay
tuned for the next session add a rich
geospatial analysis to your toolbox with
bigquery GIS thank you very much or you
could get the GS to bigquery with Kafka
and then do the geospatial analysis
there you go